hello everyone and welcome back to the
state of the web my guest is Adam Argyle
he's a developer advocate at Google and
creator of the viz bug design tool and
today we're talking about the state of
design systems let's get started Adam
thanks for being here
so I want to ask you what purpose does
design fulfill on a webpage what are its
goals mmm that's a good question
at a high level I feel like design does
a couple things we have you know it's
supposed to be guidance you want to have
credibility so that's like the better
designed it is the more credible it
feels right you don't want to spend
money somewhere where it looks like
there's no design even though that might
not accurately reflect the product or
what you're investing in but I like
thinking about at a very very high level
what design is doing is we have
affirmative design and we have critical
design and critical design is the type
of design that is exploratory it sort of
provokes you Brutalism as a good example
of critical design where you're looking
at some things like wow this is like
stark and shocking even though it's sort
of retro in a way so there's design can
do really interesting things to your
psyche in terms of like challenging you
and or we can see more of this
affirmative design which is kind of
getting more popular it's safer where
you're sort of piling on to the social
norms of like what's going on in design
because it's safe and it's familiar and
so folks will visit your site and they
might feel old into an action because
they visit it and it's beautiful and
airy and they might be looking at
something terribly not attractive like
let's say a scrubber for you know your
sink you can make a scrubber and a sink
look very nice
so you visit the site that says do you
have problems with your sink feeling
dirty and nasty we've got the scrubber
for you so it's like every design States
the problem and then brings in the
solution and that's sort of lulling you
into this behavior they're like Oz in
this familiar you're here it looks like
a normal ad it has the normal flow let
me guide you down this path and we'll
take you through this excellent
experience so design does both those
things that's really high-level to does
a whole bunch of
stuff too but yeah I think that's sort
of what is trying to do is credibility
flow you know somebody else has done the
work to organize it for me so it's
supposed to be easy I'm supposed to be
here to consume quickly and get a task
done guiding the user towards the
solution for that weapon yeah and in
that case it's usually the solution that
the webpage wants you to go down which
is where you know design has a little
bit of cunning in there some people say
design is a type of trickery as well
which right we have like dark patterns
that are like legit trickery or we have
light patterns which are it's trickery
or we're just sort of like no this is
just a healthy guidance you can you
could diverge it's okay yeah so in terms
of the tools that designers have what is
a design system and what are its goals
ooh
so a design system that's sort of it's a
hard one to nail down it's gone through
all these phases my current opinion on
what a design system is is where we
previously had design deliverables that
were sort of like a design system and
then we had engineering deliverables
that were kind of like a design system
well we have with a design system
it's a merging of the two where
designers have their symbols and their
files that generally represent the same
components that engineers are making and
there's like this
oh-hoh coming together moment and a
design system that's what I think we're
currently personifying that as we're
before engineering had like a pattern
library or component set and then the
designers had a style guide so what are
some of the principles of a good design
system ah yes
okay so at a high level I think a design
system intends to make future us have
easier decisions like in the future
I shouldn't have to invent a new button
I shouldn't have to invent a new login
form like these things should be solved
already
so at a high level that's one of its
most you know valuable propositions is
that future you or even if you're being
really considerate like
other customers of your design system
customers being maybe other development
teams or the designers maybe even like
the marketing team you have people that
want to use that those are
I call them your customers so a good
design system is considerate of them and
it empowers them but I'd like a low
level when you're implementing a design
system you should have things like
reusability extendibility
you should have accessibility built in
essentially these LEGO pieces should
have solved a bunch of problems for
other people already and and be battle
tested and have gone through you know ok
I'm gesturing right now but the gesture
is imagine a rock that I'm tumbling into
a pearl like we'll take and then we'll
have a bunch of pearls to give so that
other people can and get their tasks
done easier and also there's some
something about that where you need
interactivity as part of your design
system right I have seen some design
systems that don't just talk about the
component they give you levers to pull
so you can visit a page and there's some
tools out there that do this like a
story book is one we have other tools
coming out like framer X so there's like
design tools that are coming out very
very focused on this one particular use
case or you have ones that are a little
bit more documentation focused so
they're less like compose and build and
more like no tinker and play and assess
what component you need beforehand and I
like that tangible learning it it's
really nice especially for someone
visual like a designer to come into a
design system website and peruse and
find a component and be curious and play
it helps get really sticky the the
features and the capabilities of that in
terms of the life cycle of a design
system is it ever really done or is it
more iterative oh no I think they really
only grow I have seen them be reborn or
we you know we've seen them be reborn
with brands or they're reborn as
complete redesigns but no I don't think
they're done I think they're growing I
think we're making teams now to
facilitate these things because they are
so difficult and they only grow in
complexity because well there's
considerations that are often lost like
mobile you know a lot of design systems
are like a look at our sweet desktop
design system and they're like cool what
to do on mobile we're like we'll get
there same with like accessibility and
layouts and anyway
there's like a few other things that I
think some design systems can do to grow
and be even better and I think that's
just what we're discovering right now
like folks are playing and they're
trying to figure out what aspects of the
design system are really meaningful and
what's crufty and you know for young
industry we're all still learning kind
of like what this means do you have any
examples of older design systems that we
draw inspiration from today whoo yes
okay whoo okay so old design systems I
have a bunch of them that I'm a big fan
of we could go back in terms of like
inspiration and things that are
influencing what we're doing today and
go back to print and be like print you
made beautiful style guides or brand
guidelines you would give Legos to a
client and that client could go put them
on an envelope they could put them on
some stationery so that was a very early
set of like Lego deliverables that had
some rules and some intentions then you
have operating systems that feel very
much like design systems as well right
the first iPhone had a design system for
sure they even had a document the hIgG
right the human interface guidelines I
would like to see more Design Systems
have a hIgG that are we super cool all
right and then we had Android with Halo
these are inspirations to me Android
with Halo and remember that one dark and
glowy everything looked like it had like
lightning bolts or like neon around it
actually you know what it looked like
that would looked like that Batman movie
with it was like a UI based on that was
kind of cool sorry we had platforms we
had web kits
oh yeah so this is like material
bootstrapped html5 boilerplate jQuery
Mobile yeah those were and what they
call those right those weren't design
systems they were component libraries
but UI framework UI framework yeah
pattern libraries they had all these
interesting names I think we also take
inspiration from fashion we have this
kind of goal right now I have this
metaphor I like to think about a design
system it's like you're trying to make a
capsule wardrobe that's everyone else in
the company should want to wear right
you're like okay I'm the
designer we need to make uniform looking
things across our site and they should
be familiar and an elegant - blah blah
blah so what they do is they go make
this this design system that's
essentially like making a set of
wardrobe like you can't screw this up
just walk in the closet grab a shirt
grab some pants grab some shoes grab a
hat who cares it all goes together and
that's a that's a term from well I
learned it from Pinterest I don't know
where else it came from though but the
capsule wardrobe idea is this yeah grab
and go wardrobe and we're trying to make
a grab-and-go design system I'm gonna
hoppy and grab a couple things make a
new layout be on my way so fashion I
think is influencing us in that way too
they want to be very minimal alright
it's almost like Marie Kondo your your
wardrobe like go in and pull all the
stuff that doesn't fit in the capsule
make it reduced set like reduce your
anxiety by you know reducing your
options but I have a question about that
like when you limit your wardrobe or you
limit like your UI elements is it true
that you can have one size fits all UI
elements or sometimes you need to reach
out and use something new and different
whoo
right because you don't want to wear my
clothes do you know yeah you should like
dude your wardrobe is well it looks like
your wardrobe right like what if I want
to have my own looking clothes and this
is where it comes down to like well and
I have two opinions here one is I don't
think designers want to wear other
people's clothes so it's to me it's a
little interesting that we're trying to
unite I think the goal is super right
like that we do need to make reusable
Legos that are extendable and and are
helpful for future problems but at the
same time the more you try to abstract
and reduce these like very subjective
visual emotional things into like little
units they start to feel very functional
they lose some of that that excitement
that creativity and I think people want
to start breaking out of your design
system at that point they feel trapped
so there's like a there's a there's a
struggle here which design systems which
is we want to empower everybody but we
want to not be trapped we want to be
able to pick clothes everyday that are
really easy for us but then we want to
be able to go out to a fancy dinner
and not look like we're dressing from
our capsule wardrobe and especially if
you have customers customers want to
have unique aspects of the site and so
naturally they're always pushing on the
design system to extend even more this
is a good shout out to to material and
Google material the new version looked
at what their customers were doing which
the customers for materials tons right
people all over the world using it from
dashboards to mobile apps and in that
case they looked at how people were
using it and people were constantly
customizing it right they didn't want
material vanilla they wanted material
with my Flair whatever that Flair was
like right like I want crunch material
so oblong it doesn't exist but maybe I
should make it no but yeah that they
looked at their customers and they
empowered them to customize and extend
material as a base I thought that was
really observant and it was like
research-based it's just a very very
nice plan for the next version of a
design system to lean so heavy into
customization and enablement of people
to fork it's almost like they're letting
people fork - to manage their own and
they can still pull updates in that's a
really great segue into my next question
which is there was a comment on our
previous video in March the state of CSS
with you know Kravitz our guest and this
commenter is cool twisted TV says the
problem seeing lately is that most
websites now look the same it's like
they all have this standard template or
something
unlike back in the day when flash was a
thing people used to create
out-of-bounds designs along with tons of
nice animations but nowadays everything
is flat all gridded up the same way with
a few minor positioning tweaks here and
there I missed those kinds of designs
that today we rarely now see all because
everyone is now into this flat and
blocky design look slap a few fonts on a
page and add a few pics and color on the
background and you're done that's 2019
for you what do you think about that you
know we're gonna add an agency even
working at startups we couldn't take a
lot of risks and we were moving so fast
that the only thing to do was
affirmative
design I think what this question is
kind of poking at is affirmative versus
critical design and they're upset that
everybody's gone affirmative they're
like ah you're just piling on to the
current least socially acceptable design
patterns and strategies that's solely
which I agree
because I built a lot of flash websites
and yeah you could land on one of my
experiences and it was like you're in a
fishbowl right it's like fishing yeah
you could hover over the treasure chest
and would pop open it bubbles would come
out it was way more critical design way
more like experimentation and and
creativity was like you were unfettered
but at the same time if we think back at
that because there's I think a lot of
joy and and fun it was there it was less
serious and it wasn't really achieving
inclusive design as well I think one of
the reasons folks other than you know
you know being safe is that flat and and
choosing some these modern strategies
they really make accessibility easier
because you're not going critically you
don't have to go undo something to be
inclusive so I think inclusive design
which is a really impressive and great
push that we're doing right now it's
also kind of inhibiting some of our
exploration because we want to be able
to reach as many people as possible and
affirmative design is lowing right you
visit it you're like alright well I
don't really have to stress while I'm
here or do very much deep diving there's
the navigation menu and there's my
primary reaction but if I scroll down
you nope there's three little things
that tell me about the feature this the
features of this product
Oh Harry Roberts right today Harry
Roberts today writes this thing
basically is like recoating this person
yeah I have a quote here flat design and
the rise of more and more digital
products does seem to have killed off a
lot of that exuberance and
experimentation which is a huge shame I
missed the days of seeing what
adventurous and out-there things people
were trying to create you would log in
every day just to see what crazy stuff
people built whether it was flash or web
I feel that I think there's
there's another tweet I can never
remember them to Kaiser name I think
it's John gold huh I remembered
someone's name
Wow we'll have it I know your name -
yeah Rick Vesco me mm-hmm
screen name this tweet though had two
images up and it was like which site are
you building the one on the left are the
one on the right and they're pretty much
identical they they're like big there's
an app bar at the top there's a big
header image with big Joyner was text in
it that's like there's a problem and
then underneath that's like solution
right and they're both there and they're
the same they're like the practically
the bootstrap templates that you could
get for free they're practically the the
theme for every WordPress site is now
looks like this and the coolest and most
creative and critical ones might have a
video playing right what text overtop
like put some extra effort into that one
that pictures animated
do you consider bootstrap to be a design
system I do I don't think they do well
and maybe this comes down to where I'm
I'm curious about what a design system
is and how it's different than a pattern
library I think I think it's that
designers were more involved in a design
system whereas like bootstrap is very
developer led I think design kind of
came in a little bit later after their
Legos got really popular and so yeah I
think I think their design system that
just kind of got there in a different
way and the result the thing that they
have the tangible thing I can go pick up
off the shelf and just like place in my
tool belt right I'm I'm Wayne right now
from Wayne's World so I just grab my
like from the back of the car if anyone
remembers the Shockers anyway whatever
that's bootstrap right now I could go
get that off the shelf and be
immediately useful with it and solve my
future problems it's like the same value
props that I got and and we're sharing
about a design system you could get them
from bootstrap but it doesn't call
itself a design system I can't remember
what their home page says I think
they're one so according to the HTTP
archive bootstrap is used unlike one out
of every four websites at least in some
fashion which is a surprising stat who
knows to y'all but could that contribute
to this feeling that websites are all
looking this
twenty-five percent of the web is using
bootstrap with the same type of layout
is it possible that bootstrap is a
victim of its own success in a way whoo
I like that phrase victim of its own
success
yeah yes I I think they are this this is
funny this reminds me of two two
metaphors I don't want to share like
bootstrap is funny it like if you think
back to high school there was probably a
super cool band that their album just
came out and you were like a little dead
band so cool and you listen to him a ton
they made a second album which Chapter
four made a second album and you're like
this Bay it's still cool or bootstrap 3
and then it gets really popular and
everyone's listening to him it's like
some fool who you don't like shows up
we're in the band shirt and you're like
okay that's it done with this bit and
you start calling them a sellout and the
reality is just like they're now popular
they're now making money they're
successful you should be happy for them
but instead you're turning your nose up
and like this like defensive disgust
like yeah I don't want to use it anymore
even though all the stuff you've built
with it was great all the music and
moments you had with that band we're
really nice but it's hard for anything
to stay in fashion for too long that's
kind of like the second metaphor is like
the Wardrobe we all had favorite stores
we shopped at back in the day whether it
was zoomies or gap or whatever right and
these were like places we went to go
make easy decisions that helped us get
on with our day and that we were still
picking something like relatively cool
and meaningful but then it just gets old
we're kind of rude as humans you know we
we burned through stuff all the time we
consume it and we're like this is so
good and then we throw in the trash so I
think bootstrap is a victim of its own
success but it's also very much still a
success
I think being successful is hard I mean
look at any big framework of like
whether it's a JavaScript framework or
big design tool as soon as you hit the
big shots and like you're the cool one
everyone wants to take you down and
that's that's a hard life to be in so
bootstrap stick it out I think it's
still a great product it's obviously
just reaching a different market almost
like the pop band
all right the pop band Green
right loves their first couple albums
third one came out didn't want to play
that band anymore but they reached a
whole new set of people and those folks
fell in love with them in a way that I
didn't and I shouldn't say that Green
Day is bad I should say that Green Day
is successful in their reaching new
people and I still like their Dookie so
you've spent a year as a UX engineer at
the Google cloud team as design systems
engineer so to speak yeah what was your
experience on that team yeah that was
really I was oh so illuminating so yeah
I was a my title was really long ready
for this I was a UX engineer on the
design systems team of JCP through a
design lens so they have two different
types of UX engineers there's UX
engineer engineer and then there's UX
engineer design so I was on the design
side I was in a team of four or five
other UX engineers who were supporting
the design system which had a big team
and I this was really cool to see how
much commitment Google had to their
design system in so much that this team
was made up of three teams there was a
trifecta
like a Triforce of folks were managing
that design system that design system is
creating jobs and it was really
interesting to see how all of them were
working together what problems they were
solving there's two things I want to
point out the first one I think is
really interesting in meta which is
Google here I'll just start with the
first one it was built on angular so
it's angular which was transitioning
from material one to Google material and
angular was doing a good job at this
work the the struggles that they had
were with how many customers that they
had so this is where I like this meta
comparison you have Google clouds and
their design system which they call
their design system a condensed version
of material so it's like a child's theme
it's like they forked Google material
and made a an enterprise condensed
version that's not as airy and fluffy
that's interesting because that means
Google Cloud is a customer of another
design system simultaneously they have
hundreds of customers so they've got
customers
internal write app engine there's like
various products and each one of those
products has a team each one of those
teams are consumers of this design
system that's crazy then you have
third-party players people don't want to
add plugins or other support and other
features into GCP that also want to use
your design system so they had this
really really unique scenario where they
were simultaneously a customer of a
design system and a producer of a design
system anyway yeah it's meta I liked it
and they were really adamant and very
good at listening to all of these
different customers and trying to make
this thing work for everybody but it's a
very difficult task they're hiring they
have tons of headcount because this is
GCP is humongous and they need help that
and the UX teams they're really fun and
really cool so if anyone's looking for
roles GCP in seattle we'll put a link in
the description yeah sure so you
mentioned something earlier I want to
come back to inclusive design what is
that and what is the purpose of it oh
man this is so inclusive design we want
oh this is so funny it has a name
because I feel like it's the thing that
everybody's wanted the whole time we
want our content to be accessible for as
many people as possible right like why
did we have to put a label on that and I
think the label is there and what it
means is you need to have a site that's
accessible which really means you just
need to test first testing your site for
accessibility is always this awesome
empathy experience where you're like oh
no my sites probably fine on that and
then you go tap through you're like it
works it's not elegant and that's sort
of like inclusive design is like taking
that extra step to empathize research
ask folks and adjust your design to be
more inclusive so this can come down to
things like contrast ratios font weights
than this tab flows and stuff like that
so looking ahead what do you see the
role of components and future Design
Systems
I think we're only going to get more
complex as things go on we're noticing
now that our components aren't good
enough yet it's still especially once
you get to inclusive design areas where
you
you were done and then you go test
you're like oh we're not done sometimes
those can shake the whole foundation of
your application and I think it's
healthy though that people are
investigating that other future things I
would love to see you know voice we have
so much voice interaction coming in why
don't we have a design system for voice
I think that'd be really interesting
green lines I would like to see design
systems providing green lines green
lines are an accessibility indicator so
we're a red line is you just saying I
intend for this avatar to be 45 pixels
wide and 45 pixels tall with a border
radius of 50 percent so it's a circle
like you're it's a traditional way of
marking up a document to encourage or or
be precise about the presentation that
you want accessibility is a similar
similar push we're like I'm gonna go in
here and I'm gonna look at this little
form input I'm gonna look at this form
button I'm gonna go and indicate that
these three areas should be tab indexed
this way and it's sort of a designer
taking control of the accessibility
experience and saying and I'm just being
very deliberate and clear about what it
is they expect this to do and yeah it's
nice it's the designers making those
decisions as opposed to leaning on
front-end to doing and how about mobile
mobile is usually forgotten - all right
so we've got components or it's funny
material most of the opposite material
is mobile first and then you sort of
have to expand on a couple things to get
desktop to work most Design Systems I
see these days our desktop focused and
then they they start to squish things
down as things go so I'd love to see
mobile included more components yeah
good call how do you see the
relationship between designer and
developer evolving I want to see them
communicating a lot more John Maeda
recently had a very provocative titled
article but ultimately what he was
pushing for is a switch and strategy
where traditionally he was a proponent
of design LED he was like yeah the
designer should be at the top of the
company maybe even like making all the
decision it's like
if you do that then elegance is sure to
be achieved and that's successful in a
lot of ways but what he's seeing now
after a few years of this is that
engineering is really really important
to engineering is required in order for
elegant design to even be achieved so
what he's setting is no designer I'm
probably gonna you know butcher this
title but no designer will be more
successful than another designer unless
they're integrating themselves richly
with engineering the pitch is the
designer isn't necessarily the leader of
the show anymore he kind of says you
should be a supporting actor or actress
and even though that might be a little
hurt some hurt some hurting to your ego
you can still go see a movie where the
supporting actor actress was the star of
the show there's just a relationship
that needs to happen here that's just
richer and deeper integration designers
needs to be included more across the
wide array of design decisions that are
getting made and a lot of those design
decisions are made in code so designers
get in there meet those folks sit with
them every day and try to have rich
conversations about the engineering side
of things and getting greens they'll ask
you and they'll want your opinion I
think I feel like engineers make a lot
of decisions today that they'd rather
not make and it's just because no one is
there to do the decision-making for them
or to tell them what it is so they kind
of have to make it up as they go which
puts the front-end engineer into an
interesting predicament wait I just
thought of something else
this one is this one's huge for me okay
so we have in the front end especially
the dependency graph is getting really
popular and we have back-end dependency
graphs we have CIA CD dependency graphs
there's no designer dependency graph so
what I want to see is like two really
weird things first off I want to see
design files pub/sub where I want a
design file to publish the colors and
publish spacing units and like some of
these like really
atomic units like think of tailwind
tailwind is this phenomenally reduced
design system they have a file and I
love it because it's almost like if you
were to did you see the movie perfume
the story of a murderer no I was a
creepy movie but he did something
interesting which he was trying to
distill the essence of beauty into like
a thing that he could hold
I feel like tailmon did that they took a
design system and they looked at all the
different pieces and they started just
like organizing and and plucking them
and putting them into a nice list and I
like that JSON object I think it's not
JSON actually it's JavaScript which is
another cool feature of tooling anyway
it's JavaScript file that is the most
reduced design system into like atomic
units that I've ever seen and what I
want to see is I want to see design
files publishing something like that for
a front-end to consume and then I want
to front-end to publish data models and
other things for the design file to
consume I want to see a bi-directional
communication happening between design
apps and front-end development that I
want designers in that dependency graph
publishing values this is like why I
want them in CI CD like I want designers
reviewing PRS I want them creating PRS I
imagine this like you're in your design
file you changed a base color because it
didn't pass a contrast ratio you know
over here and some other tests so you
push and you save a change you publish
the change which creates a PR that other
people can go review designers making
PRS bypass the developer bypassed the
developer I think it's a decision the
designers were already making it just
was like this long-winded feedback loop
to get that work in they're like I've
got other crazy ideas too or I think
your design system should be a
dependency graph work clearly
articulates what dependencies it has and
what dependencies it creates for other
things to consume I'd like to see
designers making kubernetes Canary
deployments I don't even like to see I
pitched GCP on this I think there needs
to be a design focused cloud integration
so that you've got you know really rich
cloud dev tooling but we don't have rich
cloud design tooling like why aren't
there little design tabs over there that
a designer can go in create an a/b test
which essentially makes a canary
kubernetes container that gets deployed
to 5% of the users now designers can be
in control of features of the front-end
through some epic and really cool cloud
integrations yeah I want designers i
well here's a challenge I don't know how
to get designers into the backend
dependency graph I like pretty clear
ideas on how to get the front-end and
how to get them in CICE but I'd love it
if like service designers were included
in API design and somehow there was
again a pub/sub mechanism between these
two were like the API team is publishing
something and the service design team is
publishing something there's just so
much so much opportunity in this space
for designers to get more richly
integrated into the processes that are
happening on the development side it's
not creepy it's super rad like I want
designers doing cember their design
systems should be versions just like the
app and optimally they should match it'd
be really cool if like the design system
was out v 1.0 Point 21 and so was the
front end right because it was a
consumer of that version there's a lot
of opportunity I think developers would
like to have relinquished control over
things like changing colors and if the
system is built well changing the value
in one place like this master file and
having it applied downstream to every
button and everything else that depends
on that color I think they would love
that I I think so too
Mike we just need some tooling I've
there's a bunch of people working on
Apps last time I did research there was
like 15 of them but it's sort of
developers taking a design system
building it and then publishing those
Legos in like a design app and so that's
what we're seeing we're seeing a bunch
of design apps coming out where
developers are saying hey I've exposed
the levers to these components for you
in this cool tool where you can now go
compose our Legos together and build
something new and play in an almost
production feeling like design tool but
really it's still kind of prototyping
because the code it's making is kind of
you know
anyway I think we're headed towards a
really cool integration layer there
between designers and developers where
they're gonna be richly working with
each other and designers will start to
get more intimate with like minor
details about a component like what a
boolean is and why our boolean is
different than an enum and why they
should care and because those things are
cool I don't think they're scary all
does viz bug actually fit into that
vision this bug yeah so this bug school
is it's got a few of them one of them is
designer developer communication you
know a designer is often in their design
tool and over here they've got an art
board and everything's placed XY which
made it really easy for them to you know
highlight multiple and drag and delete
they had this like direct manipulation
but what is a bummer about that world is
that it doesn't translate well
somebody's always translating it so I
was like a front-end engineer I would
receive one of those and I start looking
at it I start translating it to code and
what vis bug does is it it sort of takes
what the developers are making and lets
you inspect their work like it's an art
board and I'm I'm seeing folks that are
having better communication with their
engineers because they can feel things
there's like an empathy that's starting
to happen because the complexity that is
the front-end is now something that
designers can contribute to they can go
poke and inspect and modify and an
experience why some of these things are
complex or experience how easy some of
the stuff is and so this book is
definitely in there in the game to help
designers and developers communicate
better it has some features where you
know if you modify some CSS you can show
what changed in screenshot that and send
it to an engineer so there's an
opportunity to even be like super
articulate to a developer about what it
is you need and but it's also this book
has this other goal so it's kind of
Sophie's book is kind of like Firebug
for designers its goal is to provide the
same thing that Firebug did for
developers but it's something for
designers so give me tooling that's
familiar to me in the end environment
that can help me make better decisions
and it does that I think really well it
a bunch of cool features too I'll just
like breeze over em really quick but
there's there's guides so you can hover
and see lines and detect measure you can
do measurements you can inst you can
hover and instantly see any styles that
are there and I've done a lot of work to
make sure that those styles that you see
are the ones that designers want to see
you're not going to see all the craft
there's an ally and their accessibility
inspector same deal you click it you
just start hovering on stuff and ever
tell you accessibility details
there's margin and spacing
visualizations now so you can hover and
see padding and see margin separate so
the dev tools shows them together and
mine shows them separate and I support
multi select so you can multi select
multiple things and as a designer or an
engineer see how the spacing is creating
all that white space like where's the
white space coming from is it a margin
is it pushing or is it so those are
interesting you can also create or you
can't create well now you can't create
but you can delete you can cut you can
copy you can paste you can double click
any text to change it you can change any
foreground color you can change any SVG
you can there's a position tool you can
just select something and then drag it
around the screen and totally ignore the
document flow so there's tools to help
you work with the flow tools to help you
work out of the flow it's about like you
feeling unfettered and getting an idea
out right there and and it should feel
fun like I wanted it's almost like I
wanted to break the glass for designers
on a web page like we're constantly
pulling down these magical pieces of
paper and they feel so far away for
designers like I can't change that I'll
just go back over I'll just screenshot
it I'll come over here I'll have a white
box and cover up that and you know like
make this whole Franken thing and then
ship that back to the developer and be
like please like can you do this thing
here and and I'm hoping that folks start
to do that in the browser which kind of
comes into another value prop but I do
want to cover really quickly like this
book wants to be more well I have this
phrase that's democratized the DOM and
really what that means to me is I want
the web and designing on the web to be
more inclusive I remember when it was
easier and you know we were on MySpace
and
anybody could just go grab some CSS and
paste it on the page and be like oh
that's fun that makes my brain tingle
and a nice fun way better and worse for
better or worse right that's vis books
the same way I read or worse people can
go visit a page and play but I think
what that does is it opens up for
children and adults too to feel like
they can play like there's like it's now
kind of a sandbox which simultaneously I
think we start to like when you when you
start to learn by playing at first
there's there's just something different
about starting that way than like going
to school and like starting all serious
so I'm hoping that this can help people
who are serious but also help people
that aren't that serious be more
inclusive and I forgot whatever the
second thing I was going to say was but
yeah I mean there's lots of interesting
features of his bug but it's trying to
help wants to wants to be the design
debugging tools des tools perhaps oh I
like that
so what resources would you recommend
for people who want to learn more about
design systems and everything else we
talked about
yeah design systems okay so whoo there's
folks there's three folks that I'm a big
fan of Dan Maul unic rabbits and Brad
Frost they're they're super articulate
vocal public figures that are
passionately talking about these topics
and helping you ramp up or ramp down dan
mall recently has been helping people
not over focus on the Atomics of their
design system because you can get super
like we wrapped up in a button and he
did this really funny thing at a list of
part recently he showed just was so good
he showed a button on the screen and
then showed four companies that that
could potentially be the button for and
he's like who's button is that and
everyone's like oh I don't know maybe
that one it was a blue button right and
so the point was we can over focus on
these little things and that's not your
brand and he's essentially pushing you
to real like step back a little bit and
determine like what's unique about your
business and and make make components
and designs
two out of those like your value prop
like how are you different because the
Atomics are atomic I thought that was
really nice
Yuna has a bunch of really cool things
that she's been pitching as well she's
pitching accessibility in your
components which i think is really
healthy and and she's advocating for
maybe you don't need one
so sometimes and this is something I'm a
believer in too which is often we want
to be the top dog like now and so we go
do whatever the top dogs doing we're
like alright I need you know legendary
armor I need a sword of the gods of the
ten thousand XP right and so we like we
show up when we're like level one but
we've got all the gear and we're like
this will make me good right and it does
to a point but it can also be a bunch of
baggage and like you can't even make it
through the door of the first dungeon
because you're like to cover it in gear
right you got like magic shooting out of
each fingers so I like that advice too
which is like look at the phase that
you're in as a team look at the phase
that you're in as a product a you know
notice that GCP which is a very very
large product has an entire team
dedicated to this now it's that complex
there is absolutely value coming out of
a design system but you got a look at
the ROI like how much are you putting in
versus what you're getting out and I
think that's what that warning is is
like you can spend a whole lot of time
on the Atomics of your design system you
could spend a whole lot of time making
it really robust and then nobody uses it
so you got to make sure you have
customers and anyway those three folks
are really good to go look up and listen
to they've got plenty of material for
you to study well Adam this has been
great thanks comin on the show
absolutely yeah I was really fun you can
check out the links to everything we
talked about in the description below
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]